[Music]
we've been waiting patiently for Selena
Gomez to drop a new album and our wish
has finally been answered I'm excited
for us coming on Monday the pop star
confirmed that she has new music in the
works during an interview with BBC's the
radio 1 breakfast show with Nick
Grimshaw Wellstone oh man they help
there is no might there is an album yes
and I think it's fair to say that people
know the the year I've had and I've
poured my heart into my music and I
wanted it to be fresh it wasn't really
about charts for me our numbers it was
more just about what could I creatively
do for my music so yes I can
successfully say that my inspiration for
this next album is in full motion and it
will be very soon selena has released
multiple singles in 2017
you got a fetish for money but the
singer has yet to drop a full album
since 2015's revival as she has taken
time to deal with her help she underwent
a kidney transplant earlier this year
now it's it's exciting to be in a place
where I love surprising people and
creating new areas of music I can
explore so I and I'll get to be present
you know I just I was taking some time
off for my health and it was good but
now I get to be here I'll be back how
excited are you that Celine is back in
the studio and let me know who you'd
like to see collaborate with the pop
star on her upcoming album
tweet me at Kourtney underscore teza no
and at ET now
[Music]
you